a judge in Tunisia has ordered
opposition leader Rashid randushi to be
imprisoned for allegedly plotting
against State security that's according
to his lawyer ranushi leads the biggest
opposition party another and is a Critic
of President Christ Syed he was arrested
on Sunday president Syed is accused of
orchestrating a power grab after he
suspended parliament in
2021. well in a message recorded before
his arrest
accused the government of misusing the
Judiciary to Target political opponents
the battle in our country is between
democracy and the dictatorship that
wants to confiscate all the gains of our
blessed Revolution the legal cases
against us are empty and meaningless
according to Legal experts the problem
in our country is not with me the unions
or other parties the problem in Tunisia
lies with the dictatorship and this
brutal school that is pushing the
country towards more calamities and
famines
let's take a look at what's behind the
political instability in Tunisia over
the past two years in July 2021
president kaisay had sacked the Prime
Minister froze Parliament and assumed
executive powers the opposition said it
was a coup last July saw just 30 percent
of Voters turn out in a referendum that
backed say its new constitution only 10
percent of tunisians voted in
parliamentary elections in December and
January
since early February the government has
arrested more than 20 political
opponents and public figures who've
criticized the president
I mean sanusi is a political analyst and
independent journalist joins us from
Paris good to have you with us so first
of all what do you make of the charges
now being leveled against Russia
devandoshi
well the charge is used against Russian
laranushi are the same ones that have
been used against razishi against sheima
Isa against
those are charges that are used against
anyone who is critical of by side
eyesight is is actually uh just doing
what he's been doing since February and
since 2019 always finding ways political
ways and using the police and the states
to arrest his opponents and to
intimidate them because the message is
stronger than arresting the message that
the government and high side is sending
that anyone who is critical risks to be
accused is at risk of being accused of
plotting against the state let me
present to you The Narrative of the
president and those who support them
they say the political class
particularly in Parliament they're
corrupt they were running the country
into the ground and the particular
accusation that was made against when
shortly after he was arrested had to do
with a speech in which they the
officials came out and said he was
inciting violence
well first the the the the the
acquisition the Acquisitions of
Corruptions are meaningless because side
has full Powers since in the last two
years and did he manage to get rid of
corruption no did he manage to get rid
of economical crisis no so the problem
is is not is not the parliament or is
not the the previous Constitution the
separation of powers the problem are
deeply rooted inside tunisia's economy
side is just using corruption to attack
his opponents the charges against
ranushi comes from a sentence where he
said any attempt to eliminate any
political idea in Tunisia will lead to
Civil War and that statement is is is
just a political analysis and that
statement is just someone who is trying
to say that that that I said is trying
to eliminate political ideologies in
Tunisia so really the the statement
um the statement that randoshi made is a
statement to you here in in every
political party in Europe or in the US
and you can hear those type of
statements everywhere so I just finally
managed to to get something on the rest
of anushi just like he used to do with
his or his with his his other political
opponents the the idea is arrest first
and then find the charges do you think
we'll see NADA actually banned and what
will that mean it's the largest
opposition party
well it's technically banned really they
they they they don't have the right to
organize meetings at the time they can't
access their headquarters so really uh
you don't need to ban them because you
just strip them for every political
right they have so
um really
um it's it's it's the largest opposition
group but but side managed successfully
to convince people that the NADA is the
soul responsible for the economical and
Democratic crisis in the last 10 years
well well NADA was never governing Alone
um there was a structural and difficult
difficult economical problems to resolve
but side managed to to convince the
people that that that the old system is
responsible for for the crisis and that
he's the only solution left but once
people once when people will realize
that this the side is not able to
deliver because in the last two years he
had full powers and he didn't bring any
solution to the table once the people
will realize that he's not able to
deliver we will need to convince again
we will need to talk again about the
importance of separation of power the
importance of a parliamentarian system
in order to avoid another populistic and
authoritarian figure
all right thank you so much for your
analysis I mean sunusi